maryberry I've interviewed you here a
few times on the radio a few times and I
felt like I knew you pretty well but I
hear that 40 a week over the course of
this series it discovered a dark secret
from the barre history so we had a lot
of time to chat we're together we were
stuck together mainly because I also
followed Mary home but what this is what
I love most about mary's we all feel
that we know Mary we you know we know
what she's amazing and it was week two
they were making a move soccer takes
time Mary and I sitting there in the
green room snuggled under a blanket it
was cold
always the boys didn't like it no and
we're sitting there and Mary tells me
I'm right here did I tell you about when
I was arrested quit I swear to God I
just drop what I'm not I don't just go
what and it was 20 about 25 years ago 25
years ago and I was asked to go to
America to do cookery demonstration uses
and I'm very particular at getting
everything right and I also try to look
ahead so I thought I ought to have my
recipes all the ingredients weighed out
in case the plane is late or in case the
connections on one go straight on stage
to do my presentation our cookery
demonstration and so I weighed out each
recipe in little bags and everything
together so that I could lift it out for
the first recipe and so on the carts to
the dogs this was my favorite bit when
we arrived there were dogs and I love
dogs and I was in there just ready to go
and they all three of them came up with
their noses sort of like this and they
were I thought oh come on but they
didn't want to know me they just began
and then suddenly the airport became
empty and there were just uniformed
people and I was with Lucy young have my
assistant they parted us Lucy there me
there into two cells Mary Barry in a
cell with a selection of packets
containing white powder and you see I
didn't know whether they're all purpose
flour was you know the same as our flies
that's yes this is what I marries me
because she wanted to make the the
greatest cakes possible so had it
already and is it true there's my state
I was just incredulous they were like we
need you back on set I was like somebody
else is gonna and didn't he turn to you
and say ma'am are you are you expecting
to make some money from these white
packets and you said oh I do and
[Applause]
[Music]
you